[Music]
the chairs the toys the flags
the bits and pieces of a family day out
left behind as a community who had
gathered to mark their independence day
instead ran for their lives
beyond the cordon everything is as it
was
as investigators pieced together this
awful day
from a rooftop the gunman fired more
than 70 rounds
into the crowd his community at random
among those there then warren freed here
carrying his son to safety
they made it but he his wife and his
twins are clearly deeply shaken by what
they saw and survived i saw everyone go
congruent ahead of me and then bang bang
bang bang active shooter run run run
people not knowing how to react how to
respond
just a state of fear of not knowing if
it's real or not my wife picked up my
daughter i picked up my son
and we just ran
to the car away from the scene as far as
possible but you could see people just
leaving their kids and just chaos in the
street
the suspect was arrested after an
afternoon on the run there was no
struggle and as police prepare to charge
him remarkable new detail
during the attack primo was dressed in
woman's clothing and investigators do
believe he did this to conceal
his facial tattoos and his identity and
help him during the escape with the
other people who were fleeing the chaos
his online footprint will be key for
investigators and prosecutors it hints
at a fascination with guns and murder
and this video his of the street that
would become the scene of such awful
bloodshed
but beyond his motives again the
questions over the common denominator in
america's cycle of violence guns
what's striking is that illinois has
among the strictest gun laws in the
country universal background checks red
flag warnings safe storage requirements
and yet still it is possible easy for
the wrong people to get hold of such
devastating weapons
once again another community shattered